September is coming in strong on Netflix
with more than 30 original news shows
movies and comedy specials the fat many
selections the casual viewer is going to
have a hard time picking out new
favorites so we went through everything
coming to Netflix in September 2019 to
find the best of the best just because
Sacha Baron Cohen is headlining the
Netflix original limited series the spy
doesn't mean you should expect a
ridiculous comedy a star of such films
as Borat and the dictates errors always
hidden social commentary beneath his
outrageous characters but this time he's
stepping into his more serious side to
portray Israeli intelligence operative
Eli Cohen who infiltrated the Syrian
political system in the early 60s before
ultimately suffering a public execution
you can check out the spy when all six
episodes land on September 6th this
drama about a murder at a prestigious
boarding school pulled in rave reviews
and it was released on Netflix in
October 2018 with critics calling it a
must watch series and praising
everything from the pacing to its deft
handling of sensitive topics but for all
that elite never quite gained a foothold
maybe because it's a spanish-language
show maybe because it looks like any
other time a dozen high school melodrama
well don't let those surface impressions
slow you down Elite is a smart brutal
drama and there's never been a better
time to check it out
subtitles and all it's no surprise that
Netflix bet their money on a second
season of elites which debuts on
September 6th English actor and comedian
Jack Whitehall a printed enthusiasm to
the stage that's hard not to get behind
and that same excitement shows up in
Netflix is Jack Whitehall travel to my
father which sees Whitehall and his dad
hits up exotic locales in an attempt to
bond with each other and just trying to
be a good son he's a very nice boy Jack
he's just a bit thick audiences got a
kick out of the first two seasons which
saw the Whitehall's visiting South Asia
and Eastern Europe and fans of the show
and no doubt looking forward to another
comedic adventure with season 3 which
arrives on Netflix on September 6th
what is the island exactly all we know
is that the show happens on an island
things get crazy and someone's watching
it all go down
Katie Bosworth is starring and the
premise sets up a group of strangers who
wake up on a mysterious island with no
idea how they got there judging by the
trailer for the series things take a
hard left turn into chaos after that
leaving these strangers fighting and
for their lives there's a little sci-fi
a little horror and a whole lot of
mystery and you can experience it all
when the island premieres on September
12th Funny or Die is between two firms
of Zach Galifianakis probably doesn't
need an introduction but for the
uninitiated it's basically this Zach
Galifianakis kind of interviews
celebrities on a low budget set that
includes Believe It or Not two ferns
he's interviewed everyone from Barack
Obama to Bradley Cooper and the results
are always hilarious are you nominated
oh yeah yeah for what for for Best Actor
yeah
Best Actor how's bragging camp going
it's fight time the audible web series
saw a revival and we can thank Netflix
for making it happen according to
Deadline between two ferns the movie is
being imagined as a sort of meta
mockumentary starring Galifianakis as a
version of himself we lost all
credibility when will ferrell upload it
between two ferns two Funny or Die in a
last bid to fix his reputation Zach's
hitting the road with his show so that
you can finally become a real talk show
host and get everybody to stop laughing
at him we can't wait to check it out
when it hits Netflix on September 20th
in one of the most ambitious series
Netflix has ever offered criminal
follows multiple storylines across four
different countries in four different
languages and they're each their own
show
there aren't many details out at this
time but it appears that criminal will
consist of 12 stories are mainly center
around police interrogation rooms in the
UK France Germany and Spain David
Tennant headlines the UK casts and the
whole shebang drops on September 20th
there's a killer on the loose at Netflix
is upcoming thriller in the shadow of
the moon and it's up to a Philadelphia
cop to bring him to justice
credit says Boyd Holbrook stars as a
police officer who's leading the hunt
for the mysterious murderer his only
clue is that the killer times their
crimes to the lunar circle Mumbai what
what is that I said a lunar cycle Dex
does Michael C Hall has also joined the
cast in an as-of-yet and named Rolla
look out for in the shadow of the moon
on September 27th American Horror Story
co-creator Ryan Murphy is back with a
new show the politician a violent
political comedy set in a California
High School Murphy is teaming up with
his longtime AHS partner Brad Falchuk to
tell the story of Payton Hobart
a teenager with dreams of one day
becoming the president of the United
States before he conquers the White
House however he'll have to conquer the
politics of his local high school Ben
Platt stars as Payton with an exciting
supporting cast that includes AHS
veterans Jessica Lange and Dylan
McDermott along with Zoe Joyce Bette
Midler and Gwyneth Paltrow judging by
the trailer the politician is going to
be a laugh out loud dark comedy I should
kill yes you said it look for it on
September 27th Netflix is bringing out a
handful of new comedy specials in
September keep your eyes peeled for Bill
burr paper tiger which sees the
irreverent comedian taking on topics our
range from Michelle Obama's book tour to
his own marriage you can catch that on
September 10th on the 24th look for Jeff
Dunham beside himself
for the only Comedy Hour with puppets
you'll ever need well except for
Dunham's five other Netflix comedy
specials that is finally September 30th
sees the first Netflix offering from
English stand-up comedian Moe Gilligan a
special titled momentum that does it for
all the great Netflix originals hitting
a streaming service in September 2019
now let's pivot to see what other movies
and shows are going to be worth watching
this month there are a ton of must watch
action movies storming onto Netflix in
September the streaming service is
heating up his lineup with 300 and
dontay speak for starters it's also
bringing in two-thirds of the Lord of
the Rings trilogy
the two towers and The Return of the
King all of those films arrive on the
first of the month and on the 26th you
can check out the martial arts action
epic the Grandmaster on the thriller
side of things look for American Psycho
on the first which miles Christian
Bale's transformative role as fictional
serial killer and all around the wack
job of Patrick Bateman Netflix is also
adding come and find me a 2016 film
starring Aaron Paul as a man on the hunt
for his missing girlfriend if you're
more of a monsters in the closet kind of
person you won't be disappointed
September 1st sees the arrival of the
Last Exorcism
will the 13th heralds headcounts a
creature feature about a shape-shifting
monster chowing down on a bunch of teens
in the desert from slow burning
mysteries a tearjerker drama DS there's
going to be something for everyone in
the drama category the month opens with
Clint Eastwood's oscar-winning mystic
River JD salinger biopic rebel in the
Rye and the lake house most of what
we're getting in the comedy genre is
stuff we've seen a dozen times but that
doesn't mean they don't merit a casual
rewatch Superbad is popping up on the
surface which was pretty much the comedy
to watch in 2007 haven't seen it in a
while you may just find yourself maka
loving it all over again if you're in
the right mood you can also look for you
don't mess with the Zohan both that and
super bad arrive on the first of the
month Netflix is bringing a set of much
awaited seasons of Network shows into
the fold which is great news for anyone
who watches TV exclusively on streaming
services is it worse to wait a year for
the next season of American Horror Story
it never seems like it at the time but
now that AHS apocalypse are slipping
onto Netflix on September 24th the wait
feels a little more bearable that the
shows who can look forward to in
September include season 9 of The
Walking Dead and season 3 of MTV scream
both on the first we're following that
up with season 9 of shameless on the
10th and season 5 of Gotham on the 30th
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and to
the bail so you don't miss a single one
[Music]